[Music]
let's go to milwaukee wisconsin joshua
joins us there joshua how can we help
hey how are you guys doing we're having
a blast what's going on
awesome i had a question about my
relationship and uh kind of how the
financial aspect of everything fits into
it
um i've been with the girl you know
about a year and a half and i love her
and i'm looking at engagement uh but we
haven't discussed finances in detail and
i know there's a bit of an income gap
there and i was just kind of wondering
when and how that subject should be
approached
great question so let me ask you this
you said there's an income gap how do
you know that
um i she asked me to help do her taxes
last year um i'm an investment advisor
and tax advisor cool so you know her
income but she doesn't know yours
yeah and there's no big secret the
conversations just never come up
yeah so what is the conversation like
around money so far
um you know it's just something we just
split expenses when we go out and you
know there's never any kind of concern
on my part or even hers
but we have not gone in depth in any way
shape or form you know as far as what i
have and what i make and
that kind of thing well without giving
you a specific timeline i'll say this
what's more important than the numbers
are the values
and if you guys value the same things
financially if you guys both want to
remain debt free become debt-free invest
for the future those are the things that
tell me that you will have longevity as
a couple versus who makes what but if
the fear is i make a lot more than her
is this going to change the relationship
is that part of the equation
you know i'm not overly concerned about
that but it's something that's in the
back of my mind you know i don't think
that she values that kind of thing more
than me um great values as a person
she's awesome
and neither of us have any debt anymore
um
so i guess i was just kind of wondering
when when's appropriate before you get
engaged after you get engaged
sure well here's here's the funny thing
she's already aired everything about her
financial life because you did her taxes
so clearly she's very open and honest
about this stuff and i don't think it's
a bad thing for you to do that as well
but i do think it's wise for for you
guys to be engaged before having you
know very specific conversations when it
comes to numbers because we don't
recommend combining your finances until
you're married and that's really when it
starts to matter
sure
but ken may have a totally different
approach what's your take on this kev
you know i think it's
i think you're very thoughtful on this
and i think there might be some fears i
think you've addressed the financial
stuff
you know i think you have to joshua kind
of wrestle with what are you afraid of
based on the information you've given us
you know do you think that i know you
love her
but i just heard some doubt about maybe
even the long-term
viability of this relationship
because of how she looks at money and
how you look at money am i am i reading
into that or did i hear some of that
no i you know i mean i guess
it's in the back of my mind but um
it's probably more so from past
experiences i've had nothing to do with
her you know i'd hate to
put that on her it's it's probably more
just in my life experiences i've been
burned in the past you know everybody
has what does that mean for you like you
what do you mean you got you disclosed
your income and they used you for your
money or
no not necessarily i mean i've just had
in the past i've been surrounded by some
shallower people and she is by no means
shallow it's just maybe that's why i'm
kind of struggling with the whole idea
of disclosing it fully to somebody
that's not say a business partner or you
know an immediate family member
well i think i'm hearing some trust
issues based on your past that's pretty
normal you got hurt
you know there's there's some trauma
involved with what's happened to you in
the past and so you have to get healthy
with that
and move on from it and then go okay
what have i learned so i can be smart
but as i begin to grow deeper in my
relationship with her and i share my
finances i mean what's the worst that
can happen
do you know what i mean do you think
she's going to go on facebook and share
it with everybody
no no you know so play this out you know
what what is the worst that can happen
if i share my finances and i think
actually as you as you get comfortable
doing this and again i think george is
right you guys are dating right now so i
don't think this has to happen now but
if you get to that point and you become
engaged and and maybe even before we get
engaged i think this is a great time
it's not about showing her everything in
your finances it's more about talking
about your views on
finances and your values around money
and if she is naive that's a big
difference than shallow
see shallow
yeah okay good so you get what i'm
saying there i think shallow is one
thing
naivete and not you know kind of having
any knowledge or experience with money
is very different i think it's you begin
to teacher and share with things and not
be intense about it
but
have conversations about it as you would
maybe about eventually having kids or
a religion or pilot or whatever you
would in a relationship you begin to
talk about it holistically and see how
she feels about it
um and if you feel there's still
concerns then you have to take that
serious but right now i'm not seeing a
lot of red flags
sure yeah appreciate the call young man
very thoughtful yeah very mature right
yeah i think that's great